by Kempe fresh shot clock how about that
Kimmel with the cat back rebound Hornets
head a wire-to-wire win kippa cat by the
defensive scores what defense
I mean Indiana is putting up no
resistance right now get some rhythm get
back in this game and play the way that
they normally play is gonna start with
him what a big basket the Hornets are
saying three more for Kemba Walker
Darren Collison back into guard Kemba
Walker just like the Hornets off from
the perimeter with cody zeller teammates
for a couple of years in Bloomington
Indiana Hoosiers cap the Walker
points 18 and 19 for the captain five to
shoot for the Hornets we have this gear
droplet thing abuse my favorite shot
right there for Foucault and his handle
is really improved he's got that Russell
Westbrook and talented always in fact me
hey such Kemba Walker or a three-pointer
Chico's Cory Joseph Kemba slide five
[Applause]
deep fry tempeh Stevenson passed to the
cutting Joseph he fumbles it picked up
by three beyond kept by
points 32 and 33 right is 11 consecutive
double double
[Music]
just when the Hornets need him to do
something he comes through